so today
we are going to look at systems of
equations.
Yeah, we will.
look at
systems of equations in the context of a linear programming
problem
applied to economics
So I'm going to give you an example problem in economics. And
by the way, I'll give you the reference for the book. This is
this is the cover it's from Dover.
Dover Publications, it has several example. Well more
than several examples are of linear programming
in economics and biology.
And finance. So the one I'm going to give you is
an adaptation of one of the problems economics.
and turns out to be actually relevant to
What's going on?
at this point
you know considering
What's going on out there in the world? This is something that
you know alludes to that.
so
we're going to do two things. We're going I'm going to
give you a an example.
of a linear programming problem
or LP for short
and specific to economics
Okay.
Now you don't you don't need to have domain expertise. This is just
a
I mean the focus here is the on the mathematics of LP.
So if you understand this.
Problem and the way we approach it. You can apply to other
problems. Yeah. Yes. Goyal. I'll
the I'll I'll post when I when I
start with a markdown, I'll add the link to the excuse me
the
The author the name of the publisher of this book.
So we will do that and then of course.
To plot because we have to plot.
the constraints and the optimization function
We are going to use.
Python for that so we're going to use matplotlib.
or
graphing
the lp problem
No LP problem number one.
number three
And if time allows it, we're going to talk about ludcomposition.
the composition
Which is the technique?
for solving multiple solving a system
of equations
without
manually performing
row operations and a lot and the
numpy library has
a method for solving
or
performing LED composition of a matrix. So remember the way
we go from system of equations to a solution is to
take the constants.
Or the American values of an equation or the equations put them
in a matrix. If you don't remember I'll remind you about it.
And then perform some raw operations
alternatively what we will well I
hope it would have time to do is talk about this technique called LED composition.
It's an algorithm.
it's a mathematical algorithm which we can also Implement both
python, but numpy has the method anyway, and this
method allows us to
well solved to get this lower this
lower upper triangle.
If you remember we said the solution of
a
Matrix let me grab a tab here.
from the browser
if you remember we said that if you you know that you're looking
at a solution for a system of equations if you get
Something that looks like this.
I know I meant to do this one reduced row.
Echelon form
so here
if your Matrix
Goes from looking like this, right? These are
the constants.
Of these variables and of course, these are the values on the
right side of the equation.
You know that you've solved the system of equations if you
get this.
Matrix
okay. So LED composition is one way we
can get to solution for a system of equations.
Okay.
Value the composition. I'll go rhythm.
Good.
This is well. This is a programming implementation. There's also a pseudocode.
This is the pseudo code.
I'll show you clear one, but you get the idea. So
it's an algorithm for solving systems of equations.
and
the problem that we're going to look at has only two
constraints.
Again, if you don't remember what that is you I'll remind you. I'll introduce you
to the idea moment. But in the real world, you'll have more many
more than just to constraints. Okay, and
by the way the assignment which
I will post on Saturday will be
a linear programming problem. So you will exercise your abilities on
numpy matplotlib.
and linear algebra
Of course so number four.
Lu decomposition
with python
and numpy
algorithm
and then we Implement a python.
Okay, so let's begin with the example that I'm
maybe we want to look at this economic problem.
so this is going to be
LP
example this one and Danny
can ask question. Yes, please. Go ahead.
so
In this LP problem. It looks
like you have a square Matrix. So it's all the
You know you got more.
Or you got equal number of equations as the
number of variables now in the case that you don't have it and
you only have like a solution space.
Will you be showing how we might?
look at
the objective function
to form a tangent to the
space that could give the solution
To does that make sense?
You refer to a square Matrix. We do not have
a square make which which example are you looking at by the way? Let
me go to dashboard.
And the system of the equations The
Matrix that you showed just now.
Oh you need a picture?
Yeah.
so X was two and Y was
it was
It was this one.
Right you referring to this? Yeah.
Yeah, so you got three equations and three are known so it's solvable, right?
Mm-hmm. But if you
had two equations and three unknowns
Then you cannot solve it what you're gonna
get is a solution space.
Okay, so yeah. Well, yeah, I mean now
so let me show you one more thing. Let me show you an alternative
form.
So this is in that situation you have to draw a tangent.
You have to draw the the objective function has to
be a tangent.
Or the the max hit the maximum point of the
solution space. So how do we do that using?
Python numpy. It's basically my question.
Do you have an example problem?
I will yeah, maybe I will send it to
you. Yeah, yeah.
separately
Yeah that yeah you if you have a picture of it from some
web page you can put in the chat and you know,
I can address it.
All right. Okay. So let me give you
let me give you what's going what we will do and the background so
this is LP problem.
Now picks example number one.
I'm gonna zoom out.
So it doesn't take up much more space again. You want to look here
on the right panel? Okay.
So here's the background.
We have a imaginary country.
that exports
Grains, like wheat and barley we call
countries like this that export.
Soy coffee beans and like essential food items to
other countries of bread basket.
Okay.
So when it comes to wheat, it's you know, Russia, Ukraine.
other countries in Eastern Europe many countries depend
on the Imports of these countries, so
you may have heard the news right now that the price
of
Bread has gone up and this
is problematic in many countries where bread?
is the main
Food of consumption the price goes up and
that just drives the price of many things up. It's
coincidence. Now, this is the problem because it's the one I found
in the book, but I adapt it.
To make it, you know relevant to
well, you know what we're hearing then used today. Anyway, we have this country that
exports great to other countries.
And they need to ship.
their their
their green so there is a there's a state-owned manufacturer
a government owned company that produces containers
we call these container liners. They look
something like this.
container
liner
so, you know you put these in the cargo like
they want to find in mirisk, but these are you know
meant to keep
the grain dry
It's just for cargo, okay?
now they have
two types
two designs two models
one is the standard model.
And the other one is the premium. So what's
How are they different?
Okay, and of course, we we denote the standard container
would C sub s and the premium one
would see sub pieces the C stands for container.
So the standard container can contain 100 kilograms of
barley and 100 kilograms of wheat.
Or as a premium one can hold 200 kilograms of barley and
100 kilograms of wheat.
I'm not an expert in agriculture, but
Apparel you can design containers this way. You
can mix it together.
Now this company the
state owned manufacturer now, it doesn't matter if
it's date on a private. It's just
then the numbers here are the and the variables are
important for us this company. This manufacturer has
received a quote.
to sell or provide
the government with containers
for the following
the manufacturer is supposed to
produce continuous for 30 million tons of
Wheat and 40 million tons of
body. Now I've used
This notation because when it comes to plotting it
will become easier. So we're going to actually drop the units of measurement.
So we will stick to 34,000 not just
for context it. They export
in the millions in the millions of tons.
now
what we want what what this LP problem is
about is maximizing the profit margin for
the company.
What combination of containers can we use to maximize
the profit?
So they will earn 80 cents of the dollar.
if they sell
premium containers and 70 cents for
the standard container
Okay.
and
all we need to do first.
Is Express the objective function?
So basically we need to model the relationship between
how of how much they will make.
and
then maximize this function.
So this is the objective function.
Okay.
Let me copy this bit here.
There's a lot of information going on in here, right? So
let's break it down. I'll break it down. Okay, just
give you some background first.
You put some light break in here so we can scroll up.
All right.
Okay.
So let me actually put these up here.
Because I don't want it. These are not the same. There's a different
task. So this is the problem.
tasks
and then there's the lp tasks.
So the objective function is the following the objective function
is this
They will earn 80 cents.
For every premium container that they that
they sell to the government.
And 70 cents where we stand a
container.
That they sell.
So the objective function is a function of two variables.
the number of Premium containers and the number of data containers
Not good for convenience.
We're going to swap.
C sub p and C Sub C with X and
Y. It's just notational convenience. So
we will let x equal to the premium the number
of Premium containers and Y equals
to the number of
standard containers
So this is the objective function now.
It is a function of two variables.
And this is the relationship.
Now we want to maximize this.
But we have constraints.
We have this constraints.
What are the constraints let's see.
The constraints are the following.
the first one
now these constraints say that then
the combination of containers
you use the number of continues use cannot exceed.
The amount that you're allocated.
So for example in the for wheat, we have
30 million tons.
So we need to I mean, yeah, so
we cannot exceed.
Whenever we when we solve for this equation,
we plotted we cannot exceed the quantity.
And of course the below one is for the body.
These constraints will once we plotted and
you know solve for the roots the X and y's.
We will know up to what number of standard or
to what up to what number of Premium containers we can you know,
we can we can adjust.
So the tasks are this.
Given the objective function. So let's now this
is our new objective function the one that's f of x
this is the objective function.
And these are the constraints.
tasks number one
We need to find the feasible region.
for the objective function
And then find the best point.
within that region
so we need to know what are the limitations of our parameters and then
within the within the
within the region
of our parameters. What is the most what is the
point? I'll give us maximum profit.
Okay, this is only two constraints.
But then we can generalize it for problems, but
we have multiple constraints.
So for tasks number one.
for task number one
We kind of did this in session one?
We must find the roots.
Of the constraint of the constraint functions or the
constraint equations.
To find a point outline diffusible region. So
we have two constraints and both by the way in LP problems
the objective function and their constraints are
all linear meaning they produce lines.
So we're not going to look at quadratic equations
every variable in the
lp all variables in the end. The lp problem
will have will be raised to the power one.
Not more than that.
Okay.
so
the first constraint is going to produce one line
the other conceptual produce another line and
then we need to
well find the region that does not.
Overlap into the other region you will see exactly what
this means once we start plotting.
All right.
Now what we need to do is of course.
to solve this
you must explain the constraints which are currently inequalities.
And express them as equations.
So we have the following two equations.
So you can see.
and remember 200x
X is the number of
the premium containers
why is the variable corresponding to the standard containers?
so this is constraint one this constraint to
in order to find the reason we have to solve for x and
y
so first
now, of course we could put these two equations into a matrix
and then do
Galveston elimination
But this is only two equations so we can
just do something simple. So we have equation 1 and equation
two subtract them subtract first equation from the up the
one below and then we can simplify some more. So
200 minus 100 gives us 100x.
100y my minus 100 y that
just gives us 0 y
now, of course this wouldn't appear in the equation, but I'm just putting it here. So, you
know that this is now eliminated.
And of course 4,000 minus 3,000 is 1000.
So again, we're getting we're getting closer to finding
the most points of the feasible region. Yes question. Oh,
so how can we drop 10 dish to the power for
I mean at both the places here in both
the equations.
Can you repeat the question?
So in the constraints there is a quantity 10 raise
to the power 4. So how did you drop this quantity
in both equations?
How do I draw?
Yeah, even how do I graph them?
So probably you have dropped them because the
constraint says it hundred X plus hundred Y is
less than or equals to 3000 multiplied by 10
raise to the power 4 varies in this equation two
you have you you wrote this this this this thing in
the right hand side is 3,000 only so
oh, yeah, it's quantity. Yeah.
No, I just did it because it just for convenience. But so
but this is still 10 to the power 4 and this
is still 10 to the power 4.
Yes, because 4,000 minus 3,000 probably
won't be same as yes, it
would be same. Yeah. Yeah in that way. Yeah, right, okay.
I only did this and I know this is not precise, you
know, we should keep the units of measurement we should keep but but
I did that intentionally just to
because tuning out to me too many numbers.
I thought we simply but anyway, we'll keep this.
It's a good thing you brought it up.
right
and then
We simplify. So right now we have
to find what x is equal to and what Y is equal
to.
by
performing some classical algebra Elementary
algebra. So first we find X.
So y goes out of the picture.
And we divide 100.
We divide both sides of the equation by a 100 so I can let me just simplify.
It makes up think so that I clear here.
This zero would go away.
And then we would have to get 100 to go on the other side.
and then this of course if you want to keep
our scientific notation
okay, and then
I'm just gonna leave this out for now. Okay, because
I'm gonna I'm gonna confuse myself as well.
But here we know where we this implies that this
is actually 100 times 10 to
the power 4.
Okay, I'll leave a note here note.
here
10,000 is actually
times 10
power 4
here we can I close to going to type in a Million.
tons
in the interns
Anyway X is equal to 10.
Quick comment here when we say 10. We shouldn't forget
that. This is 10 times.
10 to the power of 4
so X is actually equal to
100,000
So we found our first root. Now, what we
do is now that we know what x is we plug it in we plug in
X for the other equation.
So then we get
this bit
so we call this.
solving for x
and then
solving four y
solving
or
why?
So what we have done here.
Is we've taken equation number.
That's 100 y so they say this equation 2.
equation 2
so here
we have
3,000 again here with this implies
that it's
you know.
30 million
and
let me just make sure I didn't leave anything out by mistake.
I think I did.
Yeah, I was supposed to bring this here.
So we take equation two.
We take the 10 this 10 over here.
Right. That's our root for X the value for the root X.
And then we plug it in into equation two. So this
becomes 100 times 10.
Plus 100 y equals 3,000 or
actually 30 million.
And that's exactly what we've done here.
Okay again, just to be consistent with the notation. I
am going to
There we go. Like so
again, I don't want you to be too fixated on the
units of measurement or the scale the proportions
I just want you to see that the idea here is we have two inequalities
to express them as equation and then we solve for x and y
to find a point that is the key thing here.
So we do some algebraic manipulation right
here. We have 100 y. So in
order to move this term to the
right side, we substrate we subtract it. So 100 times
10. That's a thousand.
So now we get 3,000 from up here.
Minus 1,000 so it is this move
to the right side of the equation.
Subtracting these two we get 2,000. All
right, it's actually supposed to be you know, 20 million.
And then we divide.
we divide 200 over 100 because
you know, this is what we're getting the 100 from right? It's this one.
this 100
we bring it we divide both sides by 100 and
it gives us 20.
So in other words the root for X is
10.
And for why it's 20 which gives us this point.
Now what I want to show you.
is
plotting part 1. So again, we have we have done part 1
so far or should this task one, which is finding the
feasible region of the objective function.
So I'm going to switch to python out to show you how it's done with python how
we will use mathplotlib to plot this.
And then we'll return to find the best point for the objective function.
And that is the point.
In the feasible region that will maximize the profit.
So to do this, I'm going to open a notebook.
Let me open it up again LP example that pi.
The cells should appear.
Why is it not appearing?
No, it's not working. So I'm just going to use Co-op for this.
So I'm gonna keep this here.
And open call app.
Right next to it.
like so
new notebook
LP example
one
I would say this is a it would be a good idea for you to
follow along by the way to actually type along.
example one
Okay. So first we're not going to use numpy just
yet. We're going to use matplotlip.
Import if you're using colab this
library is already pre-installed.
So I'm going to go Matt.
plot lip
Dot pipelot
as
PLT
quick question how many of you are familiar with this
Library?
And I've used it if you know it and used it before typing y.
Otherwise type it in the chat.
Okay, fine. Okay. See some questions here. No one
asks.
Do you don't you want to minimize the objective function don't
you want to minimize the cost?
No, you're right in this example. We want to maximize the
profit.
Okay.
If we sell these containers we will
earn.
A sense on the dollar so that that's what we
that's what we want to know.
There's the cost associated with manufacturing them and then there is
the revenue we get from selling them and how
much you will profit.
Okay, of course we can turn that we can turn this problem
around then trying to minimize the objective
function if it had to with the cost associated with it, but this
is about maximizing profit.
Okay. Okay. Everybody knows math problem. I
don't need to say much about that. But let me go ahead and you know
plot this problem.
So the first thing I'm going to do is generate a
list.
of numbers
there is
A method within actually, I made a mistake. We
do need to buy import.
but it's it's just
to produce
some to produce some numbers.
Let me import no pi.
So X is going to be equal to NP Dot and
we're going to produce a linear space.
A line a set of linear set of values.
from 0
that's the starting number.
Two, let's make it 100 and we
want two thousand.
Numbers in this range. So this is a set of real numbers.
0.1 0.2.
all the way to 1,000
because the way we can produce a line.
on Matlab is to have
a sequence of points a sequence of
XY points. So we need to trace.
Along the X and Y axis.
so we have X
goes from 0 to 100.
And I'm going to express.
the constraints
as functions of Y
So let me give you the code.
So here we are plotting.
the constraints
as equations obviously not equalities.
How do we get this? How do we get this function? Well if I
come down
here
It's this one.
What we've done?
Is we have moved 200?
To the right side of the equation so we get 4,000. Obviously.
I'm not including the million. I I don't want a graph
that is that large I will label in
the graph. I will label in the X and Y axis but I'm dropping the
times the scientific notation from here,
but it is 100 y equals 4000
minus 200 x
so four thousand minus 200 times x
and to get rid of The 100.
I'm going to divide both sides of the equation.
So if we divide both sides of the equation, let me actually make
this slide. Why?
sub 1 and y sub 2
Okay, make it less this confusing.
So to get rid of the 100s.
I'm going to divide both sides of the equation by 100 divide
this side of the equation with 100 you get y1,
you get and divide.
This sort of the equation.
You could Y2.
Okay, so I'm really expressing these constraints as
functions of Y.
I'm doing the same thing here.
I'm moving 100 to the right side of the equation. So we get
3,000 minus 100. So 3,000 minus 100
and of course to get rid of the 100. I'm going to divide for
solid equation. Okay.
and then
I need to set the limits of my
plot.
Math thought about automatically set the
limits of on the X and Y axis, but I want
to maybe leave some room.
for visualization
then I'm going to plot.
both of these
equations. I'm going to plug both of these.
constraints
this is going to be y sub 1 this will be y sub 2.
Okay.
Going to run this.
So just to make it especially clear. This is the first
constraint
so our solution area is limited to
You know this triangular region.
but then when we involve the second
constraint
now well now we're confined to this
region.
And you can see we have an intersection in here.
We would have we have just found this we found this by.
Finding the roots in our constraints and
we find we found out that the point.
On the feasible region is 10 and 20.
So we can take this and we can plot to indicate it.
So whatever our objective function is going to be maximized to it must.
Not leave this area.
Okay.
So let me show you what I mean.
and
Let me read label this one. So for
the first constraint
we have X must be greater than or equal to 0 so X.
Must be greater than or equal to.
and then y must be greater than or equal to.
so plot
the
constraints
This is as equations. And this is this was supposed to be expressed.
Express they cut straights.
as functions
of why
all right.
Now the point the point that indicates the
feasible region.
We use the plot method.
The point on the x-axis the point on the
y-axis.
And then here we can choose the marker and the size of
the marker and give it a color.
so plot
the point
indicating
a feasible
region
There we go. So our objective function.
must
go through this point.
Okay, so we're getting closer to the solution.
and then
let me show you how I can fill in the region.
I can fill in the regions.
So I'm going to there's a method called.
the
field between method
so we have y sub 1
y sub 2
and then we want to plot the region.
that where
the points in our first
constraint or less than the second constraint again.
This is what this is what it looks like.
and it did not work because
because
Yeah, because we have okay, this was something else. This
was supposed to be the masking area.
So before we mask.
Then you actually plot the gray areas. So this will be through between
so shade
the regions
under the constraints
So first, we'll do the first constraints. That's
why so 1
which will give us that.
And then I'll pay for the second constraint. So why it's
up to?
Okay, and this other plot, let me
disable this for the second for a second.
We want to get rid of these regions.
So we should only see Gray.
In the feasible region, and so what I'm going to do is I'm going to mask.
These areas.
So I'm going to use the fill between method again, but I'm gonna
set the color to white and the alpha to one.
I will do this for both of the
both of these regions this region and that region.
And you will get this.
This was supposed to be white.
one more time
y sub 1
y sub 2
1 sub 2
there we go.
So this is the feasible region now.
Okay.
so this is it, this is
A task one. This is the visualization visualization
for task number one. So let me show you task number
two.
Now that we found that V7 we want to find out the optimal point.
in this solution area
So I'm going to now do task number two.
Get a return here.
and
bring the preview so you can see what I'm typing.
And now we'll do task number two.
task number two
to find
the best point
is to say the point that maximizes the
objective function so best.
as a context
if we talk about minimizing objective function and the best is the
point at which the objective function is minimized.
And obviously if we talk about maximization at Port that
the best point is the point at which the objective function is maximized.
So here we talked about maximizing.
So here if you remember this is the objective function.
It is a function of two variables.
Or X is the standard container Y is the
premium container.
And then what we need to do is find these roots X and
Y.
If we find these roots, we will then know the slope of intercept of
this objective function.
And then we will know the line that cuts through.
that point
so I'm just going to copy the algebraic solution.
Just to save us time.
Again, this is just the steps for algebra.
Okay.
Is it just steps for the algebra?
Here I'm you know, losing this
parentheses again just for notation convenience.
And then I want to solve for y.
So I can you know the whole divide we want to bring 70y to
the left side. So that's why we get Negative.
And then we want to bring F to the other side. So that's why we have minus f
Again, that's the objective function.
And then we saw, you know, we divide both sides by 70.
And then we get this.
So here if you remember.
This is a specific case of y equals m.
X
Plus p
the slope and The Intercept so MX controls the
steepness.
Of the curve and be controls the
vertical the vertical
positioning of the line.
So here what are our what is what is M here
m
Here is equal to well eight of negative
eight over seven.
Which is equal to what in decimal form?
one point
one for let's make it Round Up to 143.
one four three
and then the end y intercept.
is equal to
1 over 70 1 over 70
times f
Okay.
Now let me return to.
collab
so here f
f is equal to
80 times 10 and 70 times 20
because
if I scroll up
to f
up here
We already know what x is and we already know what Y is.
So what we're doing is we're plugging in X and Y.
from the roots of the constraints
Okay.
So we get this.
We get this if we evaluate this.
At the roots we will know.
the
we will know the profit.
When the objective function is maximized.
and then I'm going to take
this snippet
to plot
the objective function at its
maximized
You know added in at the maximum at the point
at which it is maximized.
So this will become.
and
and here
We'll come back to this in a second. Let me just paste that this
let me use instead of FF.
Oh for objective function.
So this is the objective function.
expressed
as function
Y.
again this
this bit
is equal to
This equation down here.
So we have solved F. So let me actually add let me add the
the Math teachers. We have some context.
You scroll down.
So up here. We have f
and if we plug in
again
values for X and Y
and F
You would get.
f equals to 80 times 10
plus
70 times
the 20
which would give us.
T times
10 is just 800.
and then 70
times 20
is 1400.
so all together that gives us
so what are we doing is we multiplying this term?
by 2200
so this effectively becomes
well, you know, I'm just gonna you what's up
with 2200.
And that's what I'm doing here the python.
code
close this again.
Okay.
So this is the objective function.
after plugging in for
x and y and finding
no plugging.
In values or X
and Y.
And I want to be plot this.
We get this red line.
So this is the objective function.
at its highest
So the answer to this problem is this.
you need
containers
For so, what was it again? If
you go up here we said that X is equal to
the premium containers
and why is equal to the standard containers?
And this is how we visualize it.
now
Before I you know, we turn our attention to LED
composition and I answer any questions you may have about
this particular problem.
this
example
you will use to solve the assignment that
will be due.
for next week
So the idea is the same you if you have first of
all, every single linear program will have
at least two constraints.
But the one for the assignment will have multiple constraints by the ideas the
same you find the roots of the constraints.
You find the roots of the objective function.
And then you plug in the values and then you highlight the
feasible region.
And when you do you would have known the point at which the objective
function is maximized in this case. We know the point
at which this.
Company can make the most profit for the quotation
that they have received.
Does anyone have any questions?
About what we talked about so far.
Any comments?
In the meantime, let me pull up an example of LED composition.
So
if this is not if you if you
look at the feasible region and
so if x was 0 and Y
was 30, right?
FX was 0 and Y was 30 correct? Yeah.
yeah, so
when we get a higher profit moment.
Wouldn't the value be?
if you plug x y equals 30
into this function here, the objective function
X would be zero.
Well the first you be
greater than
Yeah, but 20 you're outside
of the feasibility region. Okay. So here you see here, correct?
X equals to 30 to and Y is x equals
to 0 and Y equals to 30.
Yeah, so we said that X is equal to the
The premium ones and S is
equal to the standard ones.
Right. Let me see if I left it in here information out
here because if you are selling would need make sense to sell more premium
ones.
Do you see the y axis is not the y-axis is
not the y axis is not the
The Profit access
So, let me see if I can make this clear.
I need I need to plot. All right. Yeah, I
need to label these so.
It's not that X is the number of items you've sold and why is
how much you've made?
and the actual
profit if you want to know how much it is you would have
to print.
You would have to print.
You would print this we would go.
This is the one.
the maximum profit
or this LP
is and I'm just gonna drop this in.
Now the scale is the scale.
the proportions
So this is actually sent 2200 cents.
See my argument is this.
If if you look at 80 X plus
70 Y and we use the optimal solution of
x equals 10 and Y equals 20, then
you get 2,200 right 80
times 10 plus 70 times 20.
but if you made
Y equals 0 and x equals 30 then
you get 2,400.
which is a higher profit than
so here here if we set X to
0.
And then we said y to 30 we get 2,100 right?
And then now you just said if what if we set
well actually equals to 30.
And then y equals 2 y 0.
y equals to zero
Okay.
But you have to consider that then you'd be outside of your
constraint constraints.
Yes, so our constraints is what?
However, you said this equation. You cannot exceed.
So which one is this?
the 3,000
well, we are not.
Ex. Okay. So again this point you cannot choose
a given the again you're supposed
to choose it the very the values of the variables
of the objective function such that it falls into
this region. So if you pick a point outside
of the feasible region sure.
But you cannot accommodate that.
You cannot produce the car. You
don't have enough containers or you do not have
enough grains for what you can supply containers
so I can say hey I will if I
I will make the most profit if I sell.
5,000 containers but no one's buying those containers.
That's what the constraint is saying anything. No,
this is the this is the most if this is
how much for example customer you have or this is how much?
Items you have to store.
And you want to sell enough or so the
the correct combination so that you you can Encompass
you can contain all of the Green in
this case and then sell them.
So if you pick something out here if you if you just sell a
premium containers.
Well, then you're violating the constraints.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I mean 30 is still within the constraint with the
feasible region. How is it wouldn't
visible region the feasible region is the gray area.
Right. So x equal 30 Falls within that doesn't it?
No. No, it's just this is x30.
This is it. It's here. Sorry y equals that
white.
I got it wrong. Okay, so why yeah. So again, if
okay if we said y equals to 30, I just did that see.
Here I set sorry.
Let me one second.
So then it's the other way around 30 times 0 exactly
plus. So remember this is the
what this is. Yeah. This is why and this is why it's less
exactly.
Sorry, yeah.
So you can pick any point across on this red line.
And then you can of course plug in the valley see how much you're getting. So this is
the Mac. This is the point at which it's maximized.
You can play around with us now. We can go. How about if we make it 11 and make
this.
Make this 19.
And is this within the feasible is this within
the feasibility region? Well, let's see.
for y
it is but for x
I think if we added that for 11:19, we'll see
it's not in the gray region.
See that again, please. If you added that
like you did for 10 comma 20 out of
that for 11 19.
Oh, okay. You mean okay. So if we do
that's a good point.
So if we do 11 and 19, let's make a different color. Let's
make it blue.
11 and 19
Yes, you're correct. It is outside the future. It is outside the region.
Yeah, see this is okay.
So I don't get into one of the country Institute probably violate the
constraint. Yeah. Yeah you correct. I don't know why I
was
Yeah, I got my coordinates from but yes, you're correct.
So, yeah, exactly. So if you put blue it is it gives a
higher it gives us higher profit, but it is outside the feasibility
region.
So that doesn't count.
but my point was the point I was trying to make with
this right now was that
What were we saying? We were talking about. Yes this point being outside
the feasibility region. So let me you lose.
lose that
all right.
Run the spirit again.
run all
and bring back vs code.
Okay.
We have 15 minutes. So let me not spend too
much time on this I think.
I highlighted the key points.
So the the primary tasks
you have to perform for
for LP problem.
And like I said, there will be an assignment which we will be very
similar to this one.
now let's turn our attention to
LED composition by the way
Since I I you know, I was cut off. I
just want to make sure if any if anybody says any
questions any other questions
about this before I while I switch for.
the example with lu
ella says no, okay.
All right.
So let me show you this.
It's from Wikipedia.
I'm gonna show you this page from Wikipedia because I don't have
it written in advance, but
you'll get the idea.
Okay, great. Now my keyboard.
My track put it my trackpad
is stuck.
l u decomposition
Wikipedia
So remember
that we said if you have a system of equation.
equations
you need to get your
Matrix into this form
What we have these zeros.
Or we have trailing zeros at the bottom and once
on the diagonal.
So well, this is why it's called Leu we have the lower.
And then the upper.
so lower upper
that's what they recoveration does a decompose The
Matrix into the lower number.
Now we can use this technique.
You know to solve specific equation. So this is the effect
that we want.
What if you remember we said that we want the ones across the
principal diagonal?
this diagonal business by the way is very important, which is why in modules
2 and 3 we're going to spend
or we're going to spend two weeks on Square matrices
and in particular this idea of the principle diagonal so
we will talk about determinants characteristic polynomial
the DU decompet LED composition.
so then once once we will learn different types of matrices and
in particular Square Matrix
and the application of the square matrices we can
then finally get into principal components and if you remember from
the slides
you will PC has very broad applications.
Whether it's pattern mining in or pattern finding a machine
learning.
to being able to invest
Excuse me, predict the price of stock. I don't know. I don't like that word many
people says many people say experts and finance. You cannot
predict the price of stocks, but if you were to attempt
to predict the price of stocks LED composition
would be
one of the most effective ways to do that.
to dimensionality reduction
reducing the dimensions of your data, which is a
You know a very important part of machine learning.
Because in module 4 we are going to focus on New Orleans
Works PCA is going
to be so I hope you know that a machine learning. We have a few stages.
There is the model part the machine learning part and then there's a feature engineering part.
So in modules two, and three we will learn the linear algebra.
That allow us to PC and then later on understand Matrix operations
for new electrical government module
4. Okay. Let me show you the algorithm first
of the LED composition.
Not the code version.
the pseudocode version so l u decomposition
pseudocode
because I want to show you more mathematical form of
more mathematically formal way of expressing
the idea because you know
Well, let's do it. No, this is not good enough. Let
me let me show it to you.
You know, sometimes we get lucky with Google Images, sometimes we
don't.
Okay just passes but if I type it so if
I pick a page the page of this chapter.
Really you decomposition would be page.
Again, I know I promise to give you
the books and I will the reading material.
So This Is How We Do It
All right.
Let me write down the algorithm first. So the algorithm is
as follows.
we have
a for Loop
So we enumerate.
We go from y.
as excuse me, I
so we go from one two all the way to when
And then we have an inner loop.
So we have J equals.
I Plus
one I plus 2.
And then I Plus.
and rather
and these are going to correspond to the cells within
a matrix.
so
Then we will have.
Ms. Sub
IJ
Is a colony cause means we're defining it. So.
If this was a python that you would
be critical variable or you would access a particular.
element within the multi-dimensional
array, and then you will set it to
this ratio
and AI
Now what is M. What is M. Actually m is.
a multiplier
M.
Is called the multiplier.
and
we have our R is
equal to
a scalar a scale or some
so RJ equals
i, j times r
plus r underscore
G
now I know I'm gonna run out of time before I do this. So as soon
as the workshop is over. I'm going to show you the python implementation
so we go from pseudocode.
So we go from yeah we go from the pseudocode to the actual python
implementation.
now
like I said, there's a numpy implementation for this but
I mean, it's not very helpful. If you just use every everything that's every black
box method. You actually want to know what's going on the
hood.
What else do we have we have?
It is this order. I'm not sure what it stands for our subject.
It's the role.
It's the row so where?
There's the multiplier.
in The
Matrix a
and what this will do.
There's actually this is the L part and this should be a U
part.
It will produce a matrix that looks like this. Let me
grab.
some latex from the other
file
so I want this by the way this document from session
two has been updated. I've fixed a
few mistakes added some comments.
So you'll be using this as reference for all of
the other sessions and of course the assignments, so let
me grab this Matrix.
Oh, sorry. This is the one Matrix.
It will look something like so.
you will have
ones across the diagonal
you have ones across the diagonal.
0 elsewhere
and
below the diagonal we will have the multipliers.
So this would be
minus m
2-1 where two is the row number one is
the column number.
And this would go on and on.
third row First Column
and then
all the way to to end
this would be in my end M sub n
1.
so the nth row
Okay.
And so we need one on
the diagonal.
I need more columns. But anyway, I'll make this.
Another multiplier. This would be
2.
And then the last one will be one.
It's messed up by the ideas this let me make
this a zero.
the point that the point I'm trying to make is this this algorithm that
we sync up here is is going to help us to get to reduced
row Echelon form
without having to
If you if you saw in the linear programming example, we
had to man, you know, I had to do algebra.
And it took a while to just solve two
equations.
and they were not and
there was no need for multiplying a term with
one equation. It was just subtract subtract subtract.
But even with that it was time consuming it gets.
Much more time consuming once you add a third
equation.
And of course and like I said in real world problems, you could have multiple constraints
or like five ten or so or even more constraints.
So we need something.
Some sort of methodical way to solve equation and
this is really what I'm trying to get at.
this led composition
Okay now.
I have to finish I have to finish this file, but
I'll add it to the dashboard once I'm done. So right after the works after
I stopped the recording.
You will find this under your dashboard. Just let me say this before
we run at a time.
Going to come to the dashboard here.
linear mathematics
big number
first Zoom crashes and then the keyboard is Frozen
now the URL doesn't open up.
You know that Murphy's what is
it called Murphy's?
Murphy's Law
If something can go wrong, we'll go wrong. This is you're worth the
sink it right now right here, but let's just let's just
give this a second to open up. Let me just
add my finishing my closing remarks and then we can add a
session.
On a scale of what to five I want
to do this again.
How clear was this LP example for
five Crystal Clear one?
You know completely.
complete all over the place
Okay. Okay. This is very good.
Because it wasn't much interaction with just me going on a
monologue. But if it's if it was clear, that's that's great.
So you should make the assignment for module
would a lot easier why is this taking so long to load?
So, of course this third session will be the recording for
this will be live. By the way. I'm going to timestamp them.
I know it's not to convenient to have to watch or move the
scrub around so I'm going to timestamp the videos.
then
you will see by the way. Yeah, and you will see the assignment for
module one on by Saturday.
So no later than salary you'll find the assignments. And of course it will be you have an
entire week to work on it.
Okay.
Any question comments?
One of the things by the way, I'm gonna ask you is almost gonna post
a survey.
On Saturday very just two
or three questions.
Because I want to see your suggestions for making things better.
Obviously one of the things to make it better is not have to go through this but besides
that anything that has to do with the material or delivery.
I would welcome your suggestions very much.
Okay.
No, I don't think the
I don't think the website wants to work today.
It's my connection like more likely not so much the
website.
Now it's not going to work.
Okay everybody. So I'll post I'll post
these tutorial the stupid.
the completed
HTML tutorial of LED composition
and I'll have an update here on slack for the assignment.
And documents for today, okay.
That's it for today's session everybody. Thank you so much for joining me
and I will see you on Monday.
Okay.
We're now take care of my.